[Musique]
la 7e édition de l'opération premières
pages s'est déroulée ce mercredi 28
octobre à la villa du département
partenaire de cette opération depuis
sept ans le conseil départemental a
offert aux bébés nés en 2016 un des
premiers livres de leur vie une
opération qui vise à sensibiliser les
enfants à la lecture dès leur plus jeune
âge c'est important parce qu'en fait on
prépare l'enfant à maîtriser
parfaitement la lecture mais au delà de
la lecture on lui donne les outils parce
qu'il ya aussi les illustrations en lui
donne les outils pour être pour être
inventifs pour rêver pour et puis pour
se construire et mieux avancer cette
année le choix du livre a fait l'objet
d'un concours de création littéraire
sans deux propositions ont été faites
c'est l'oeuvre de visage original riels
d'amis non mairie et non qui a été
sélectionné c'est un petit comme au
caractère vraiment indépendant un petit
peu loufoque
à qui on va dans une bonne raison de se
réjouir donc moi j'invite tous les
enfants qui possèdent ce livre à le lire
et à découvrir l'aventuré rococo aimé de
ses parents et de tout un village aussi
préfinale l'éducation de ce petit coq se
fera et par ses parents et pour compte
un village de s'attaquer à ces extrêmes
des parents enchantés car désireux
d'offrir à leurs enfants le goût du
livre et même les illustrations déjà la
maison et emprunte toujours de sa soeur
et en plus il aime beaucoup les animaux
donc voila et puis si c'est un livre
avec plein couleurs comme ça ben il
s'intéresse à tous et en même temps ben
bon plus tard c'est pas d'initiatives
façon d'être de l'enfance
c'est génial quand même les enfants ils
s'accrochent très vite et tout est fait
pour que les papillons sont dans les
yeux
après ce lancement à la villa du
département les quatorze mille familles
qui ont eu un bébé en 2016 seront
invités à retirer le livre dans toute
les pmi et bibliothèque de l'île
[Musique]